what i'm going to do today is i'm going
to do some shadowing in arabic egyptian
arabic and persian hi steve kaufman here
to talk about shadowing a language
learning technique
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so
shadowing is a language learning
technique that i believe was developed
by professor
argeles alexander argellas and you can
google for him shadowing alexander arges
or argeles and you'll find a number of
videos that he's put out on the subject
the gist of it is
that as a means of improving your
pronunciation
and preparing for output
you can while listening to something you
can try to speak along like imitate what
you hear copy what you hear
even if you drop the odd word or the odd
syllable
this is a practice in i guess focusing
in on what you're listening to imitating
the pronunciation
and i have tried it in the past and i
found that it was not something that i
was able to continue with i just wasn't
motivated to do it i preferred you know
the more relaxed approach of either you
know at an early stage in my learning
listening to repetitive material like
the mini stories or as i progress to
things of more interest to me i would
focus in on you know the content what i
was listening to and i wasn't
really that keen on sort of almost
interrupting the flow of listening to
whatever i was listening to by trying to
say you know to imitate what i heard
however
uh i'm willing to try anything uh if
it's effective for language learning and
i thought to myself you know hey i
thought i will do a video on shadowing
and then i said to myself well you're
kind of negative on shadowing because
you haven't done it so maybe you should
perhaps
put more effort into trying to use this
technique and then see if it's effective
in other words be a little more
open-minded
so what i'm going to do today is i'm
going to do some shadowing in arabic
egyptian arabic and persian
uh
and but i thought to myself and of
course
if you follow alexander argelia's he
suggests that we do the shadowing while
walking briskly and there's even a video
of him doing this he's shadowing in
chinese while walking at a brisk pace
um i'm not going to do that
certainly for the demonstration i've got
no one who could film me walking at a
brisk pace it's a little more difficult
to arrange
and also i thought to myself if i'm
going to record myself
imitating someone then i think there
would be benefit
in listening to myself
and i think even our yeah suggests this
that this is a way of noticing where
your pronunciation say strays from
the uh the native speaker
so what i want to do is i'm going to
record myself
uh and i'm going to be listening to the
uh
the lessons these are
linked lessons listening to it on my
ipad but in my airpods
while trying to imitate what i hear
and but and i'm going to do it in the
two languages and then beyond that i'm
going to do it a little bit more over
the next little period and then see if
listening to
you know my own voice trying to imitate
what i hear
if that improves my pronunciation
improves my comprehension
prepares me for speaking because up
until now my main
strategy has been a lot of listening and
reading and then when ready
more and more speaking so that i
practice my output while speaking with
my tutor
and i work continue to work on my
comprehension because even if i
understand my tutor well i often find
for example in farsi or even in arabic
if i meet someone in a store and they
start speaking
on a subject that's not familiar to me
it's more difficult than when speaking
to my tutor because it's kind of i can't
really anticipate what the person is
going to say
so
i've tended to want to focus on
comprehension but maybe
you know shadowing helps on
comprehension i'm going to experiment so
without further ado
let me try to set this up now
cuz
a
okay
so that was egyptian arabic i am
familiar with these contents and even
professor aguiles recommends that he
says that's a good thing because you're
used to the cadence and you're familiar
with the content because the objective
is try to imitate what you hear even if
you stumble
iran i'm in the middle of this lesson
here by the way
hood received
okay
okay that was a demonstration so i'm
listening and i'm trying to
say what i hear as i'm listening at the
same time so that's shadowing i maybe
don't do it justice but you can look up
alexander argelias and find out more
about this technique
but what i'm interested in doing i i
don't know how much the actual shadowing
itself helps maybe it helps i don't know
again i've only got so much time to
spend so am i going to spend the time
doing that or reading or listening to
things of interest i don't know by the
way i don't do these anymore
but what i want to experiment with is i
think in particular if i can do enough
of this
that i get
some audio files like say i do the whole
lesson less than 20 any of the many
stories that's
five minutes
and each one of these episodes of
iranian history is about five six
minutes
and if i do
the shadowing for the whole lesson
and then i listened to myself
is that
sort of going to help me develop my
speaking ability or improve my
pronunciation that's what i'm going to
experiment with and maybe in a few weeks
i'll do another video and i can report
back to you and i'm also interested of
course in hearing uh your own experience
with shadowing so thank you for
listening bye for now and i'll leave you
a couple of videos on output that i've
done in the past you may find those
interesting